moi je pense que je n'aime pas aller les
al ahly est donc là il ya effectivement
de même il y avait en effet eu un
phénomène d'emballement pour cette
figure qui résistaient aux l'état major
militaire qui dirige la birmanie et là
il ya l'emballement averse à 180 degrés
je me méfie je me méfie de ces al ahly
et donc je ne vais pas jeter la pierre à
autant souri qu'est ce qui se passe mais
il se passe
il y à là le cercle vicieux de
l'attentât terroriste contre des
policiers birmans ont fait part son nous
des gens d'al qaïda et qui appartenait à
cette communauté et ensuite la
répression comme on a connu un peu
partout qu'on accumule dans la guerre
d'algérie on a l'impression provocation
répression
comment comment régler ça c'est très
difficile ça participe ça participe de
ce qu'il faut bien appeler une guerre
des civilisations il ya une guerre des
six nations il ya une bière destination
qu'on n'arrive pas à éteindre chirac
lagney mais c'était ridicule de l'année
il fallait bien sûr il faut bien sûr
vous voir l'état il faut que les
religions dialoguent ensemble il faut
que le christianisme le bouddhisme
dialogue avec l'islam
mais aujourd'hui partout on voit cette
guerre de civilisation qui n'existait
pas il ya 40 ans il y avait aucun
problème quand j'ai commencé ma carrière
de grand reporter l'islam ne posait
aucun problème on n'en parle jamais
voilà est aujourd'hui partout il ya ce
problème de guerre de civilisation avec
une radicalisation d'une frange de la
jeunesse musulmane qui représente bien
sûr pas toute la communauté musulmane
mais qui est qui qui est quand même
extrêmement nettes avec des phénomènes
de répression c'est très dangereux et ça
devrait et bien sûr ça devrait être au
premier chef
l'obligation de nous dirigeants macron
trump ukr de réfléchir à ce problème de
réglé de situation qui ne fait qu'ils ne
cessent de sa talents d'accord